[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
entreprises et collectivités le défis de
la cybersécurité
il ne se passe pas une journée sans que
des milliers d'entreprises et de
collectivités territoriales subissent
une cyber attaque
alors que la cybercriminalité se
professionnalise la délégation aux
entreprises s'est saisi de cet enjeu
majeur
dans un rapport publié le 10 juin 2021
sébastien meurant et rémy cardon alerte
sur l'ampleur du risque cyber
à l'issue de leurs travaux il apparaît
que les entreprises intègrent ce risque
de façon croissante bien qu'inégal
quant aux collectivités territoriales
elle souffre d'un manque de budget et de
personnes qualifiées
en 2020 près de 30% d'entre elles ont
été victimes de rançon j ciel
face à cette menace la stratégie
préconisée par la délégation aux
entreprises repose sur trois piliers
tester alertés et protégés décliné en 22
mesures concrètes
le dispositif cyber malveillance point
gouv.fr doit être mieux promu auprès des
entreprises et un service d'urgence doit
leur être dédiée en mobilisant des
jeunes en service civique disposant des
compétences numériques adéquat
pour renforcer la résistance du tissu
entrepreneurial
le rapport recommande par exemple de
mutualiser les responsables de sécurité
des systèmes informatiques pour les pme
déployer des équipes de réponse aux
incidents informatiques dans les régions
et d'organiser régulièrement des
exercices de simulation
en parallèle un crédit d'impôts à
destination des chefs d'entreprise et
des salariés des pme pourrait prendre en
charge une partie des dépenses
d'équipement et de formation à la
cybersécurité
le rapport avance également plusieurs
pistes pour renforcer la réponse pénale
à la cybercriminalité notamment en
augmentant les effectifs spécialisés et
en mettant à l'étude la création d'un
parc national de lutte contre le
cybercrime
surtout la délégation entend faire de la
cybersécurité un enjeu national
elle recommande à cette fin le
déploiement d'une campagne massive de
promotion des métiers de la
cybersécurité ou encore l'instauration
d'un cyber score des plateformes
numériques destinés au grand public
mais il faut agir vite avertit la
délégation
l'internet des objets va étendre de
façon exponentielle la surface
d'exposition au cyber risque quand
parallèlement l'ordinateur quantique va
démultiplier les capacités d'intrusion
pour découvrir l'ensemble des
préconisations
consultez la synthèse du rapport
[Musique]